we turn to our friend from Fox Sports as
well as the athletic Bruce Feldman here
on the program how are you Bruce
I'm good rich I'm speaking to you live
from probably the last football place
you'd ever want to be seen okay where
would that be in your mind Bruce it's in
Big Ten country but it's not a place
look the Ohio State University as you
know is a fantastic football Factory and
a tradition rich the spot so I'll have
no problem being caught alive there
Bruce there you go so you've got you've
got the Ohio State game against Nebraska
this week that's your game we yeah we do
I'm actually here first I'm 20s and
stuff okay so I hope to do some
trick-or-treating to come back on your
on Thursday so it's gonna be interesting
to see how Ohio State responds I was
getting drilled by Purdue okay how is
urban Mar Bruce how did you find a
through good question it is a good
question you know yesterday a video
ability who has asked a bunch of times
about his health and his future here and
I honestly it's a topic anywhere near
more of it's not going away just about
his health issues he's battled his
assists in his head and that has been
something that we did a game of three
weeks ago here against Indiana
he had eating his a little medical
attention for a little bit he said he
was fine but you know I think that's
been kind of a subplot to this season as
he's dealing with a lot of stress and
obviously the start of this year with
the all the mess from the Zack Smith
scandal in his three-game suspension I
think that's only added to it and then
when they got blown out on the road by
Purdue I think a lot of people are
looking looking at it saying what's
going on there is he gonna is he gonna
be the head coach here next year and I
think that the health part a piece of
this is we don't know a ton I suspect
we'll find out more not in a not too
distant future but at this point that's
been kind of a big subplot here in the
wake of of everything that that was so
messy in the beginning of the year he
said I plan to be there you know I mean
that's the when you hear coach use that
language infusing it with with the you
know the the
point whatever percent that it's
possible I mean Lincoln Riley saying
similar things in a way when asked about
an interest maybe in the Browns job that
he enjoys in that regard what are they
gonna say that is correct I mean he's
not gonna sit there and go yeah you know
I love the Browns I'd love to I'd love
to hang with uh with with Baker Mayfield
do you let's just hit that one do you
think that that is a viable option when
it all push does come to shove next
January Oklahoma seasons done Carla
Marie's done and Browns come knocking on
the door as it they might what do you
think I think it's an interesting
intriguing situation I mean look who's
the hottest name and football right now
it's the young guy who's who's lighten
it up for the Rams and I think there's a
lot of people who are looking and going
hey an innovative sharp young mind seems
to be working and so I think he's gonna
have some intriguing options now the
difference between Lincoln and Sean
McVeigh is Lincoln has never spent any
time working in the NFL I mean he's been
a college guy since he worked under Mike
Leach who knows where he's gonna be I
mean I know who he knows he's got a good
situation he works for probably the best
ad in college sports in Joe Castiglione
he's got a young family that is pretty
settled I think he's surrounded by a
staff of guys who know him well but he's
gonna have he's gonna have some big
decisions to make going forward they had
to let go of Mike Stoops Bob Stoops his
brother who's the defensive coordinator
at midseason and that could create you
know a question he's his one of his
mentor's welcome appeals handling it
right now but so there's some big
questions around Oklahoma but he's got a
good team and and they're gonna be in
the thick of the playoff race right up
to that point we know he's got a hot
name and I suspect there'll be a few
other college guys who may you know
people may kick the tires on them from
the NFL standpoint give me some names
what do you think I could see some
interest about Matt Campbell the Iowa
State head coach I mean he is a he's a
mountain union guy from Massillon Ohio
he is really impressive Iowa State is
very fortunate to have them I mean he's
done oh he's done a terrific job there
he did very well at Toledo I I don't
think there's a lot of people who look
at Matt Hamill I think he's gonna jump
all over the place you know when he gets
his big opportunities I'm not sure that
he's gonna jump
I think people are gonna look and I
don't think they really know what he's
gonna do
wouldn't surprise me if some some other
opportunities came James Franklin's way
he has spent a little time in the NFL
he's done an amazing job at Penn State I
could see him getting some interest I
mean those are those are names that kind
of jumped out at me the other one who's
a little bit of a wild card is Jeff
Brohm who's a really good offensive
coach at Purdue they obviously they
drilled Ohio State a couple of weeks ago
his stock is high I think what could
make it complicated is people have
always thought he was gonna end up at
the Louisville had coached from there
Bobby Petrino's having a disastrous year
if Louisville can find a way to get out
from under his buyout meaning if they
can find a reason to fire him for cause
they're gonna go after Jeff Brohm hard
it's just a matter of can they get out
of that contract because I don't think
they can afford to buy him out amazing
how that turned so fast with Lamar
Jackson going pro huh amazing how that
fast
yeah I never scandal with the ad above
him and you know it's no secret a lot of
the trends not exactly the most warm and
fuzzy like boy so now it's going bad and
a lot of this stuff is blown up in his
face there's not a lot of people in
Bobby Petrino's corner all right Bruce
all been here Fox Sports and the
athletic here on the show tonight we get
our first college football rankings no
surprise is going to be it's gonna be
Alabama Clemson Notre Dame and LSU
correct probably that Clemson Notre Dame
piece could I'm sorry the LSU Notre Dame
part of that could be flipped but I
think that's going to be the top four
and you look at at Alabama doesn't have
a lot of great wins but just the eyeball
test they've been destroying people and
so I think people have a lot of
confidence in them but the the reason
why it's flipped is just because they
they'd want Notre Dame to play Alabama
if because they actually treat it as if
is if the playoffs were starting today
so is that yeah the reason why they'd
flip it I think the part could be
because yes beating Michigan is looking
like a really good win but LSU just
really good Georgia team beat them by 20
LSU has I think some more impressive
wins but they do have a loss I mean it's
against a good Florida team in a tough
place to play but you look at they you
know whipped miss Mississippi State who
I think will be somewhere in the top 25
certainly in blue out Georgia
one on the road at Auburn which is which
is a good win so I could see LSU may be
number three but you never know I mean
it look look at this point pump the
brakes on it it doesn't really matter at
this point it matters I think it matters
part of the most for it is it gives you
a picture on what they think at UCF
because every year the playoff committee
makeup changes so it's hard to read too
much into what they think from year to
year what they really value but I think
for the people looking at it going well
UCS 120 in a row and Scott Ross did a
really good job I mean the reality is
their schedule has been putrid so far
and the committee usually the one thing
has been kind of consistent with them or
these the most consistent factors if you
haven't really played anybody even if
you have a zero in the in the loss
column they may not be inclined to treat
you so well and it's just their their
schedule to this point is not good and I
could see them not being in the top 12
at this point now Bruce what I'm about
to say I realize comes from the realm in
our business as a hot take okay I
understand it but I'm gonna posit to you
what I posited to Joel cloud on this
program last week because the conference
championship games I think are useless
and I think Alabama proved it last year
where they didn't even play in theirs
and then won at all so why wouldn't it
behoove Alabama to lose to LSU this
weekend at LSU in a close one just to
avoid Kevin play the conference
championship game let LSU try and beat
Georgia and then sit back and make the
Final Four anyway because they're gonna
win out if they stayed let's say they
went out I know this is supposing a lot
but why wouldn't it be benefit Alabama
to do that and have that happen I mean
in theory it probably would and the
other than the fact that what is a loss
do for the confidence of some of these
younger players because we're talking
about you know it's not just - its Quinn
and Williams and Deonte thompson there's
they've had young stars emerge in a big
way I think I think Nick Saban be able
to handle the young confidence I think I
think he's looking he's looking for
these guys to get batted around
themselves now obviously doesn't want to
lose
but you know I wants to avoid the rat
poison to use his phrase so let him let
him let him get humbled and there is no
way that the committee no matter how
much they might hand ring over schedule
there is no way a one loss Alabama
losing at LSU is their only loss gets
held out of the Final Four I don't think
there's anything on this green earth
especially if two has got that trophy in
the case I don't think that at all he's
gonna have no I I think you're right I
mean I think you're right I don't think
Nick Saban wants to know to do that but
I think you're right look there's a
probably a realistic shot that if LSU
loses closed and keep in mind they're
really missing the best linebacker in
college football for the first half
Devon white if they lose close and then
win at Texas A&M and they're ten and two
especially if Georgia comes into the SEC
title game and plays Alabama tough
there's a chance you could have a 10 and
to LSU team that's not speed the fourth
him in the playoff now I would I would
if Michigan wins out and gets a chance
to own leave unlost a Notre Dame which
hasn't have any losses that would be an
absolute abomination Bruce and that's
what again Michigan for me and I'm look
there's so much more to be played this
game against Penn State there's the Ohio
State came in the horseshoe which so we
all know is I don't even want to go
there but if Michigan wins out they've
got to put it all in the line against
the Wisconsin or a Northwestern team
authority beaten I mean for what for
what possible purpose would the Big Ten
championship game exist except to put a
dagger in the heart of their team's best
shot at winning a national championship
it makes no sense the way this is all
set up it's so bass awkward that it
makes only sense to give eight teams and
automatic bids for the conference
championship games so a team like
Northwestern or Wisconsin could still
play themselves in and biggie Cinderella
at least at least losing in a conference
championship game to a team like that
you give a shot to the team that wins
right yeah I think look is a very flawed
system and for a lot of the reasons our
point now
I don't think that's a bad idea
five-five automatic bids and then three
at larges the the part that's
challenging to that is the schedule gets
longer you'll hear some of that then
it's like okay dude do we really want to
have a conference title games well those
conference championships are bringing a
lot of money for those schools so you
know they gotta figure something out
with that but I think there's gonna be
some push to expand eight at some point
I just think for there's too many
conferences that are feeling like
they're gonna get squeezed the pac-12 is
gonna get squeezed this year and it's
not a stretch to think the big 12 could
get squeezed because now a Notre Dame is
undefeated potentially even if Notre
Dame is 11 and 1 and once a no-name
loses to Northwestern this week and I'm
beat USC and beat Syracuse their name is
gonna feel like they get snubbed if
they're 11 and 1 and so there's a lot of
stuff to be sorted out never mind all
that UCF / Houston's or you know if you
feel like they don't have any realistic
hope no matter what they do you know I
could see there being momentum to go to
eight but right now this is a system we
got and it leaves it into this like for
a while people thought this debate stuff
is was a good thing about college well I
don't think it's good I think it's I
think people will talk about the sport
anyway they don't need us to have these
kind of kind of nonsensical arguments
where it's like it comes back to well
everybody sucks that's what that's like
the default for this it's just not it's
just not the right way I don't think
Bruce say hi to everybody there in
Columbus for me okay well I know I know
they love me there now seriously they do
they do they talk about me so much this
I only take it as love you know that's
your glass is half-full thank you thanks
the call Bruce safe travels
trick-or-treating with your kids at
Bruce Feldman CFP the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience